President Trump plans to visit
California next week for the first time
in office
Wally's there he's expected to discuss
his administration's lawsuit to overturn
sanctuary policies in that state
attorney general jeff sessions announced
the lawsuit in sacramento yesterday
California's governor called it an act
of war John Blackstone is in San
Francisco John good morning good morning
well about 21% of America's undocumented
immigrants live here in California the
lawsuit asks the federal court to block
three state laws which the Department of
Justice says interfere with federal
immigration activities and are
unconstitutional protesters in
Sacramento greeted Attorney General Jeff
Sessions with chance is the supreme law
inside sessions addressed a crowd of
local law enforcement and said
California's sanctuary City laws
undermined federal law he singled out
Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf for informing
the public about recent immigration
raids and he claimed letting eight
hundred undocumented immigrants get away
how dare you needlessly endanger the
lives of our law enforcement officers to
promote a radical open borders agenda
but the Oakland Mayor fired right back
how dare you vilify members of our
community by trying to frighten the
American public into thinking that all
undocumented residents are dangerous
criminals the Justice Department's
lawsuit is the latest in an escalating
feud between the Trump administration
and California which has resisted the
President on marijuana policies climate
change and immigration I'd like to see
Washington building bridges
Nawal California Governor Jerry Brown
called the suit a political stunt
vicious rhetoric of an administration
that wants to divide America and hold on
to power by blaming other people it's
tragic it's finally on American and
California we'll fight it in every legal
way that we can conceive
and that fight is likely to go all the
way to the US Supreme Court now
California will argue that enforcing
immigration law is the duty of the
federal government that the state has a
duty to protect the rights of all of its
residents whether or not they got here
legally John okay John thanks so much